now what could we possibly do with this
what kind of options do we have I could
expand now my initial instinct would be
like gross i had expended expanding
usually makes things worse but then
again sometimes you have to make things
worse before they get better okay now
there's a reason to think there's a
reason to be suspicious that this is
actually going to work out reasonably
well because of this angle appearing
twice okay wherever you get conjugates
huh that's a coincidence where are your
conjugal this is why we call them
conjugates cuz they go together in
useful ways and you often get something
not that messy up so let's take that
suggestion let's expand what's the
expansion for this sine X cos pi on 6
plus cos x sine pylons okay that's fine
right b is minus sign now this here this
expansion is very similar to this one
but what's the difference there's a
minus is this with a minus sign it's
going to be sine X cos pi on 6 minus cos
x silences that's all equal to a half
paramed okay by five but look at it look
at it because of this conjugate thing
here you get this huge cancelling taking
place this guy on this guy vanish then
you've got a double negative so you get
two of this guy that's equal to a half
this is not looking so bad after all
right because number one I can take two
over which gives me a quarter right and
number two I know exactly what so
politics is it's a half right so I can
take that over as well I probably should
just let the drive from the one side and
then
I reckon you should be able to handle
that one now what did I do that you
didn't do well the short answer is i
expanded but why did i think to expand
answer I didn't know what else to do
with it right and often they'll give you
questions and they'll phrase in a way
wheel we deliberately we look research
we're hard for questions that are free
is differently to what you're used to
but can still be solved using methods
that you know Josh fine just don't be
intimidated when it looks a little
different one more thing in by the way I
know you think this question probably
has like nothing to do with a question
like this I think it's this something
like that I think that's one of them
right you're like this guy and this guy
look like they have absolutely nothing
to do with each other right maybe they
do
just think just don't forget right you
know how we said oh I don't know what
else to do so I tried this right we
could expand this we could but I'm
probably don't want to however however
i'm giving you it i'm giving you a big
clue that this actually has a lot to do
with this so think about